[Music]
[Music]
welcome to willy's wonderland spend the
night cleaning willy's wonderland
and i will pay to have your car fixed
deal
you are officially on staff let's get
the hell out of here
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
this place
has a dark history i know the [ __ ]
story they told you
it's a lie you're here to be a human
sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to me
machines got out
he's not trapped in here with them fear
trapped in here with him
it's birthday time i enjoy a man a few
words
you must heed my words before i'm gone
my son
[Music]
now you will be king
[Music]
but the throne must pass to a male heir
akin it appears you have a
son he must be found prepare the royal
jet
we are going back to america oh hell no
your majesty
come on
say it again
sing it again
it is so good to see you well abby damn
look who done come up in here
yeah and ebola famine and blood diamonds
nelson mandela and winnie those hungry
babies with the flies on his face
that's too much now you stepped over the
line now we won't be talking that kind
of [ __ ] about the hungry babies you're
going to get out of my chair politically
incorrect
so what you doing back here hotel rwanda
[Music]
you knew him didn't you then you had
that one little feeling
but you waved it away
you should have listened to that one
little feeling
just like i'm listening to you now you
can talk to me
i'm all a friend you got
you're not exactly a department favorite
thing's probably changed a lot since you
left
you still got to catch him right yeah
not that much exchange then
i can assure you all we are taking a 24
7 all hands on deck approach to these
cases
guy's a shark if he stops he dies he
likes to drive probably has a decent car
maybe two
high mileage they must really like my
car
i do how's the trunk space
something i gotta know how's the guy
with the best clearance rate in the
department work 15 years without a
promotion
maybe i didn't go to the right church
when i look in your ass what i see
it ain't good
[Music]
he knew all the details but he wasn't
within 10 miles of the killing why hate
that
why is that
[Music]
how's the trunk space
[Music]
what do you want i want to nail the
bastard for
all of the girls he killed
[Music]
i want to know the difference is
i'm doing this for me
it's little things jimmy it's the little
things that rip you apart it's the
little things that
get you caught
[Music]
superheroes stand watch when danger
closes in
and save those in need but they have one
thing in common
they never show up in the real world
until ulysses
every superhero comes to us with a
purpose
we don't always see it at first
because we don't always know where to
look
[Music]
flora what is this
i am ulysses born a new
holy unanticipated occurrences
did you type this
he's a superhero but
do you have any enemies i'm here about
the squirrel danger lurks everywhere
is he he's flying
there was a change in the air
and the world was filling with
excitement
people look to the skies for someone to
save them
so the universe sent us
[Music]
ulysses
can you talk okay that's not really
talking but still
i have a picture of my head of a place
i don't know if it's real
but it has a feeling and the feeling's
real
hi my love hi dad i wanted to talk to
you about my graduation
i'm going to be there in the bleachers
i'm going to see you in your let me let
me how about i call you back
taking the day off in here your boss
wants to see you
i get a whiskey double you're real
sorry i want to show you something
really cool
you see all these people outside they're
not real
this is a simulation
you ready
there's my guy welcome home this place
is
overwhelming dr isabel clemens pioneered
brain box simulations ugly simulated
worlds to
generate appreciation for the real world
why am i not remembering any of this
don't worry about it most people say
ignorance is please but i say
you have to experience the good
so appreciate that
you know the other way around exactly
i'm glad i caught you word on the street
there have been problems with isabel's
research
i'm a little disoriented you're my guy
graduation i did not forget it's been a
crazy few days
i graduated two weeks ago ignore her
she's not real
she feels real
i'm scared your head's not on straight
it's almost like a trick being played
great this is really bad
so how do we fix it
one of these days you're going to have
to choose
between these worlds
[Applause]
it's amazing how easy
humans can get used to even something
spectacular
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
erica you haven't ever wished a family
would adopt you
have you nope
anybody who choose me would be pretty
unusual
we'll take this one for the first time
in my life i'm being made to do
something i don't want to do
now then let's you and i get a few
things straight
my name is bella yaga i'm a witch
great you agree that you'll teach me
magic
and i agree to help you out if you work
really hard
i shall do anything to hurt you
i love potion for the boy next door all
of these are pretty useless to me
the spell i believe you're looking for
is somewhere towards the back
hang on you actually talk of course i do
just not very often
in this household there's one rule
that's crucial
you must on no account for any reason
ever dare disturb the man
drake don't be rude
a hole left by a witch
[Music]
i'll be learning magic well so i was
told can't wait to start
it's 20 years since the moon was hit
electricity for only an hour a day
barely any food and all you care about
is cozmo
[Music]
attention unregistered teleportation
his power is unbelievable beyond
anything i have seen
all we have is now i like you
i waited for this stepping in here makes
everyone nervous
fear not the game is more dangerous than
it may seem
all the hardships earth face are a
result of the war with cherno
we're about to go play football with
what's essentially a nuclear bomb
and everyone else thinks this is just a
game
is that right pretty much it yes
it's easier to risk your life when you
know you're supported by millions
even if they don't know the truth or
understand the risk
four young earthlings with incredible
powers
you show there is something to be
inspired by here we go
like the masses i wasn't all
when i first laid eyes on all the things
you all
i heard that speech i knew we make noise
i just thought it'd be in the streets
the black panthers are the single
greatest threat to our national security
our counterintelligence program must
prevent the rise of a black messiah
you're looking at 18 months for the
stolen car
five years for impersonating a federal
officer
or you can go home what do you want
get close to hampton the black panthers
are forming a rainbow coalition of
oppressed brothers and sisters of every
color
neutralize him by any means necessary
[Music]
america's on fire right now
and until that fire is extinguished
nothing else means a damn thing imagine
what we could accomplish together
we can heal this whole city you ain't
telling me it was going to be like this
these ain't no terrorists we got a rat
man
does anybody else know about me no one
knows your identity are you sure
we educate we nurture we feed
and
[Music]
you get to go out there and talk about
dying of revolutionary death
because you don't have another person
growing inside your body
anyway there's people it's power
[Music]
all right nelly my neighbor's passed out
on the floor
and i can't feel her pulse does the
little girl have any family members we
can contact
family members
i can hardly take care of myself this is
your responsibility
grow up hey music
i'm your sister all she's got now
is you
[Music]
hi there i don't know what i'm doing
music it's your friend ebbo
i live next door can you move in
she can understand everything you are
saying to her and if you are happy
press this very funny troublemaker
she sees the world in a completely
different way from us
we're about to have a full party i am
[Music]
happy
love you too
you can do this
i'm gonna help her just like she helps
me
and i'm actually learning how to laugh
because i love her
[Music]
tuesday january 1st 1856
with little pride and less hope
we begin the new year
[Music]
who is that good afternoon
i'm tally abigail
[Music]
i hope i'm not keeping you from
something i'm glad you've come
the meeting who has made my day oh how
pleasant
and uncommon it is to make someone's day
i guess i'm supposed to offer a toast
what my husband means is he's so happy
to finally get together did you miss me
yes our farm is a slaughterhouse right
now my husband is killing his hawks
and i resolved to visit you so that
there would be something in my day other
than his meanness
so what do you think what do you think
about us i don't know how to put it into
words
it's been my experience that it's not
always those who show the least
you actually feel at least
now seven an earthquake knocked down our
house newborn
earthquake the dread never
fully went away what was safe if the
solid earth could do that
when the day is done my mind turns to
her and i think
why are we to be separated
i don't feel i have a wife i have
certain expectations and you have
certain duties
we shall sing like birds in a cage
we haven't seen you for days have you
been ill
what's happening are you in danger
do you know what memory it is that i
most cherish it's if you're turning to
me with that smile
once you realized that you were loved
and joy astonishment
and joy
[Music]
you're strong you're important
you matter
[Music]
says what happened someone destroyed my
house
where's carl i think someone took him
who would say call
sue local banker carl buttons
abducted from his home in what appears
to be a violent struggle
hey vic carl's in trouble turn on
channel 2 news is there anything you
want to say to the people i know you're
out there carl
i know i'll see you again oh
[ __ ] they kidnapped my brother should i
get my gun i'll get my gun
mrs buttons usually in a missing person
case people called the police before
they called the media
carl said sweet man why would anyone
take him
this is a photo of me and carl in case
you need it for all the
press conferences didn't you think of
someone you might want to harm your
brother nope
oh dear nope nope people don't fear you
i can't trust you to handle my business
if people don't fear you
i shoot you in the face with this gun
that's my vagina you're gonna shoot me
in the vagina no i respect that area
it's not nice to point guns at people
paul isn't the guy who gets kidnapped
he's the guy
runs off on his wife if this whole
kidnapping thing is fake
you need to come clean so if you did
something
i can help you are you afraid what
yes i
am strong not enough you got a body i am
important
don't you think so i think so too
it's been a weekend of horror in yuba
county a weekend of chaos and loss
can you uh not kill my vibe it's a good
day don't you think it's a good day
[Music]
i've done nothing wrong i just want my
husband back
i swear these white [ __ ] are crazy
these are sharks but they can fly
you say
no flying fish stands between me and my
passengers
put the skies in the marshall it's the
only way that we can be safe
that's what i like to see
hi paxton we heard london's in total
lockdown we are all locked in the
psychological prison of burning
aloneness how's linda
she's somewhere in the house is there
some type of issue
we are fine
[Music]
not only is everything not okay nothing
is okay linda said she was planning to
end our thing
nobody wants to live alone in two weeks
we are locked together here you know you
think i'm so
happy and normal no i i'd never accuse
you of being happy and normal
shaky ground i've been furloughed now
there is literally zero purpose to my
life
i'm going to get provisions we need milk
bread
the nice people that i fired they were
fired because of me it's not about the
virus it's about who i
am and what i do for a living you fired
them well thank you
is that a glass of wine yes yeah it is
we have a situation for example all the
major department stores are closing
they want everything over the next four
days we have a problem at harrods we
have four million dollars worth of
jewelry someone's gonna have to pack the
valuables up i believe you are a man who
can be trusted
yeah i am yeah i can be trusted
it's gonna have to be something that we
trust so that means inevitably it's
gonna be me
it's a new dog what are you taking out
of harris a diamond
yeah the bastards who told me to fire
those people they are bad for you and i
are good
good is better than that you're talking
about stealing a diamond three
million pounds live wild or die linda
and i'm feeling good
carrots is the most glamorous store in
the world
i know all the security guards i know
the security systems
i just need to get the gentleman's name
his name
edgar allen poe edgar allan poe wow
what can go wrong lock down one last
ride
i'll load the world in heaven oh give us
the sum of deception
please report to
who'da thought security month ago we'd
be doing this not me
and i'm feeling good
ready for tonight i'm as ready as a
person can be
after the fight we're all coming back
here for the champs of victory paulie
don't be late minister malcolm x good
news the chariot is coming
you know what lagrange that's right jim
brown takes the ball your record is
going to stand the test of time
how's everybody feeling tonight all
together yeah
new heavyweight champion of the world
say champ you don't suppose you could
sign an autograph yeah of course man
give him an autograph jim actually mr
cook
oh sure thing brother
don't you think it's about time to party
tonight there's a chance for us to
reflect
hey you mean no one else is coming
well this is all to a hopping star
you all are a bright and shining future
you need to understand what is at stake
here
everything's not so black and white like
you make it out to be but we are
fighting for our lives
you know i know what's going on out
there right
listen listen
brothers and sisters listen listen
[Music]
[Music]
the goal is for us to really be free
ourselves
brothers could move mountains without
lifting a finger
what's your name senior sergeant
kalashnikov
the red army needs a good submachine gun
it's been said you have no real
education
we would have to pull men and material
from other projects to focus on yours
but that is not
an option here
rumor has it you're designing a
submachine gun is that right yeah but
andrei said that i
and dredge was talking about working
hours
war is not yet over
all this hard work was it just a
complete waste of time
[Music]
you